you like him no what do you like about
Andrew Tate I just don't like a lot of
his viewpoints I think they're just
misogynistic can you give me an example
of something he said about women that
you don't like
um
I really don't know anything off the top
of my head I really just hear like
things online
um you can't give me one example you
don't like this guy you think you should
be in jail you have to be able to give
me one example
okay well here's one thing he said that
that a man should look after a woman
like a man should pay for a woman a man
should protect her what do you think
about that I agree with that one so it
sounds like you do like him I'm giving
you a couple of examples and it sounds
like you do like him I like those few
points